[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soir les enfants
bon je crois
patron je descend vite chez mes petits
amis
je vais leur montrer mon bon livre dit
marc niakhar nonos mon et shan l'eau
propre à pompe à protons bonsoir les
petits mais oui
voulez-vous que je vous raconte une
histoire quelle histoire
samedi jour de la dame n'est qu'à casser
mais oui les drôles
voilà cornichons paix dans la forêt là
sur la plage combat de la mer il s'est
perdu que je suis bête mais oui notre
petite amie s'est perdu son papa et sa
maman
le cherche partout avec dada avec dada
bien sûr et il rencontre un vieux
vitryat qui pousse une charrette bien
lourde des cornichons qui est rageante y
aident le vieux vitrier a poussé sa
charrette
il arrive dans la grande ville où il y à
de grandes maisons et le vieux vitrier
gris nez
et cornichons qriocity
voilà la grande table bay au sel alors
ne voyait pas moi non plus je voudrais
un verre euros pour remplacer celui que
j'ai cassé une autre petite amie lui
découpe à pau vers ça car elle il met à
la place de celui qui pense rôle et tout
le monde dans la rue rit on la montrant
du doigt et la dame qui s'est regardé
dans une glace se met très fort en
colère mais le vieux vitrier ne se fâche
pas il sait bien que notre petit
corniche on est un peu dans la lune et
pour le remercier de l'avoir aidé il lui
offre une merveilleuse grosses
bouteilles en verre de venise il met les
pertes qu'elle agira lui a donné mais
oui allons les enfants
l'histoire est finie nous allons nous
coucher pas de suite ne nous voilà ce
qu'ils sont gentils nous est cher bonne
nuit bonne nuit les petits la jettent à
la ligne 1 à 2
[Musique]
alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui
eh bien allez vite vous coucher on n'y
va pas trop en route mon cher nounours
pas des nuits fait pour
oh
à